très bien nous sommes allés et on va
retrouver tout à l'heure le commerce
bachelet nous sommes allés au 27e
bataillon de chasseurs alpins d'annecy
en haute-savoie
c'est une jolie région vous nous avez
choisi cette ce lieu parce que nous
voulions voir à l'intérieur d'une
caserne
comment ça se passait alors un enrichir
dida on sont allés voir cette vie d'un
appelé on voit les différents aspects de
la ville pas seulement dans la caserne
où ça commence mais également sur le
terrain donc boulot quand même pas
s'imaginer pas trop pas que ça allait
être comme ça quand vous voyez plus à
scouts du sport la vie au grand air
puis finalement c'est une discipline de
vie qui est astreignant cas pour un
petit bout quant à jean 92 compagnie
d'éclairage et d'appui section anti char
chef de pièces à mon nom mon colonel
pour midi auprès de quoi survivre et on
reste sur le terrain la journée
ce soir on revient on passe une courte
nuit réveil demain matin à 6 heures
départ 7h pour la montagne
je
ces couvertures biens pillés le bord
franc face à la porte pour sonia visible
entre les draps rouler mais on reproche
sur la couverture et de traverses imposé
de suite pour autant que le canot vous
comprenez s'alarmer c'est pas du tout
parce que ils veulent une armée qui soit
vraiment performante et l'entraînement à
l'instruction de ne correspond pas du
tout et pour moi personnellement à ce
qu'ils veulent parce que disons que
faire des marches de prendre km bon bah
c'est pas avec en faisant des marges et
30 km qu'on arrivera à combattre un toit
sont ils armés d'alkyle comme ça je
comprends pas il devrait pousser
l'instruction où s'il veut vraiment
avoir quelque chose de correct
il ya du bon et du mauvais ouais ya du
bon et du mauvais mais quand même on n'a
pas l'habitude d'être commandé comme ça
marcher au pas faut dire je vraiment
idiot c'est d'aller manger aller manger
au paillage chantant
après les classes la compagnie de combat
complet de combat c'est très amusant on
bouge beaucoup
on s'éclate tu fais quoi là là je fais
quoi j'attends mon groupe là je me poste
en les attendant qu'ils traversent la
rivière
ensuite nous allons attaquer la petite
falaise en escaladant ils passeront
beaucoup plus est à l'extérieur
là bas c'est beaucoup mieux pour nous on
met beaucoup plus et ça passe autant
on dirait que tu fais un peu la chasse à
l'homme oui si on veut dire c'est
vraiment simple la chasse à l'homme mais
en fait c'est ça
dès que il est normand dès qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui se pointe on tire dessus
voilà tu le ferais un vrai un jour je
sais pas et je pourrai le faire en vrai
hier vous avez attendu cinq heures un
truc comme ça
il ya beaucoup d'attentes alors voilà je
vais attendre sûrement deux heures
encore comme ça avant d'aller en face
pour attendre ces incultes heure juste à
côté là dans le trou
qu'est ce que tu as appris alors
on vous répond
si vous êtes dans les services c'est
parce que vous n'aimez pas le sport je
vais demander qu'on paye qu'on voit ça
je pensais venir faire du sport à
l'armée bon moi je me suis retrouvé ici
parce que j'étais menuisier qui les
donnent menuisier mais bon ben
maintenant je suis bien là quoique quand
je vois ce que ce que font les cons pays
combats ont eu lieu la cible un
électricien ici pendant mes classes si
je me suis retrouvé ici quoi bon pour
moi c'était un an de perdu parce que
j'aurais voulu faire de la montagne de
l'escaladé tout c'est comme ça le bilan
après huit mois de service le bilan est
plutôt négatif
on n'a pas l'impression d'avoir perdu
son temps il a énormément de temps qu'on
passe à ne rien faire à rester tout
l'après midi voire toute une journée
comme soif donc sans aucune activité des
activités niro affaire va faire une
partie de foot d'un sympathique d'accord
mais personnellement je serais peut-être
commencer l'activité militaire
proprement dit
toque de faire rester un an ici ou
vraiment par moments on a la sensation
d'être complètement inutiles et
complètement complètement largués on
nous fait faire des pompes torse nu avec
son fusil on en disant social et mon
fusil c'est aussi ma femme ça fait très
un militaire ne pense pas il agit on
vous dit certainement de faire on vous a
dit ne pensez pas mais agissent et
exécuter des ordres docteur pourquoi les
appeler supporte-t-il si mal armés c'est
une moi je pense que c'est une attitude
générale dans la vie c'est le fait qu'
ils sont intolérants aux frustrations et
que le service national n'est pas exempt
de frustration et de l'obligation
d'obéir les
les gens que nous recevons sortent
souvent de
du milieu scolaire et donc connaissent
accord assez mal les problèmes de
problème d'emploi les problèmes de
d'ordre et d'obéissance à une consigne
il est certain que ils ont du mal à
parfois pas tous bien sûr mais ils ont
parfois du mal à s'adapter
reportage d'anne cruciaux et didier
daran chez vous au colonel je suis